ok welcome everybody we are we are now
more or less halfway through Brazil week
so just to let you know of course we
started in Curitiba with Jaime Lerner
then we were very much in in Rio with
oscar niemeyer film and with anisha
tornado in the evening then last night
at the Planning Association was very
interesting discussion of the Olympics
was I think a really super event now we
go very democratic so we have three
different cities in Brazil it's called
young practices in Brazil young
practices means anybody less than 100
years this is a Rio reference point and
we have asked our good friend and Angela
boogie too to make the to take over the
evening and to make the evening let's
say abre Brazilian evening Angelo's
somebody whose work we're deeply deeply
admire and was part of a conference here
i think more or less a year ago making
houses that like like a number of
architects in south pole or make houses
that are really far too good i think it
would be probably important that we keep
a secret how good these houses in South
follow our because they make a big
problem for architects in the rest of
Brazil but also in the rest of the world
it actually should not be that that much
concrete can hang so so beautifully so
it's really just an excuse to bring
hello back he's also teacher in the in
the foul one of the key schools of not
just over the city of Sao Paulo but also
it's very much that sao paulo school in
the sense of the the thinking of the of
the architects i think it's really great
to have these not so young architects
pretend to still be young they are doing
incredibly beautiful work and you can
see of course outside in an exhibition
curated by 0 / on day
the director of the other school the
kind of counter school the kind of
downtown Frankie school the kind of anti
foul school the sort of child of school
the kind of adolescent school the kind
of rebel school and so on let's say the
the dialogue goes between these two
schools the established school in the in
one of the most famous architecture
buildings in the world versus the school
that's occupying like a kind of a
squatter in the downtown and between
these two scores tonight between Angelo
as our moderator and 0 as our curator we
keep this kind of sense of Brazil as
much more than a country as a kind of a
landscape for real debate about the
future of architecture this is a
fantastic laboratory in which simply
some of the best architects in the world
are exchanging like aniston a tennis
match amazingly beautiful designs
designs that have a lot of relevance for
us here I think in in the in previous
moments that the the beauty of the
Brazilian architecture was almost like a
problem it was almost like a way of
admiring the work of Brazilian
architects but not taking it so
seriously as if this beauty was somehow
a tropical escape from the problems of
the city the social problems economic
problems and so on I think the vision
now is much more complex and it's really
possible to understand much more
carefully the way in which the
intelligence needed in these houses and
the intelligence needed in other cities
has some kind of a dialogue and that's
very much being the spirit of this
Brazil week and also of our schools
interest in being deeply deeply
literally in the let's say in the
intellectual jungle of Brazil so anyway
welcome to to to Angela who's here and
and 0 who's here by way of his
exhibition it's it is also an amazing
thing if you look outside on those walls
this is only ten years being monitored
and it's very much a selection it's a
highly edited selection of highly edited
images of highly edited projects so if
you understand that this is just the tip
of an iceberg you understand that if
you're an architect and you have not
visited Brazil then you're an idiot and
if you're an idiot you should not be
this room right so you have one here I
give you one year to go and have a look
at this work and then you can come back
anyway Angela welcome so much mark thank
you very much for more than four dis
introduction for the invitation no it's
the nicest invitation that I ever had
because I came here just to enjoy some
of my friends presentation and and I I'm
experience in a way kind of new feeling
because I feel that the older man now
introducing the young generation and and
I i think that the young generation in
any place around the world they share
more or less the same challenge and it's
like if they were the group that are
exactly in the front of our activity and
the challenges is because we are working
in a nativity that has to redefine every
time what is its point its subject its
body it's it has to be near all the time
so we are here of course that we in
pursuing Harriet a lot of of those
amazing works for modern art that's in
Brazil in dot that glorious time some of
us had the privilege to be in touch with
some of them at the universe but I feel
that all these
priest and they would be like an
institution I mean it would be maybe to
code and to be part of our life so what
is the way how those things could come
to our life i think that is this kind of
group of friends the people that are in
the same place almost the same room and
i think that the young generation has
also this mission that is very very nice
that is to provide to this institution
that we hear it to the proper like
breath of life this kind of fresh that
the things has to have to have a meaning
in our everyday life so another
challenge think that i think that this
young generation they face nowadays and
that is one of the ìiî also i feel like
that I'm telling to do these guys that
came here to to lecture I mean like to
suggest topics me but things that I I
think about I think that we share
nowadays a challenge that is to face
lots of research and the lack of meaning
to do what we are doing so I think that
a very important task for an arc that is
to work very hard trying to find meaning
in your work we have thousand of
requirements that does not feel our our
life or our
existence or and and when I think about
that and sometimes we could think that a
place like Brazil could be closer to
this meaning but that's not exactly true
because it could be closer because in a
place where we know very our demands
that we have to build millions and
millions of houses we could consider
that we know more or less what we have
to do but it is not so true so maybe we
could consider that in Brazil we are
more closer to the demands that here
it's more challenging to to find the
proper criteria to choose among these
lots of reserves that are much more than
we need that we have to use in one
single project and but I think that our
two ads off the same problems and the
same problem exactly this this question
so in your choice i think that was very
it was great i mean to invite to come
here one arc that from real bad as you
know is the city where our brazilian arc
that architecture was found by the
action of a very small group of people
you know the the very remarkable role
that was played by loose Acosta in this
it was some it's amazing to me for
instance that Lucy cost and one day he
decides that the Brazilian modern
priests death would be liquor busy it
was a decision no it's like if a group
of people could decide
which inheritance we would like to have
and I think that actually we can choose
these as well and I think this is a
quite modern condition so to me it's
very remarkable that we have cell
Eugenie's here that will is always think
his work from this perspective from this
context in Rio and Bruno campus from
energy rise and Silvio that is also here
from his office as well or you're off
with that there is a one more person
that this is also another feature that
means remarkable nowadays in Brazil know
all the the three options that were
invited to come here they are made by a
group of Arc deaths this is a way that I
think that the young generation Brazil
they found this way to to find a way to
to work so it's a very it much more
played by a group much more like money
fast than something that is to made by
an author I think that the architecture
now has this kind of very light way to
be done so when this group they could
sometime be combined with other groups
know in your work it's not a complete
disaster it was Justin but I mean they
are very flexible in general so I think
that you learn how to work in in our
contest and this is very important in
our context because there is no other
way to restart be an arc that in Brazil
if not like founding in your your own
off
to collaborate to some huge us maybe or
but I not a huge ah sorry there is no
huge offices in Brazil I mean to
collaborate with a very remarkable work
that sometimes but mostly to work with
his own peers that are the people that
are sharing our everyday work and and
and miniaturize is interesting to be
here as well because of course that
Mina's one more time played a very
important role in our modern
architecture we could mention two things
pump olya and in Brasilia that's not
miniaturized but was completely made
possible by su Selena kubicek and Mina's
again is interesting to be one other I
was just considering about I think that
there is a another character risk in
Brazilian modern architecture that is
the same group exactly that found this
architecture in Brazil they also are the
group that found the historical arc that
architecture and these two fields were
very well murdered in energy rise as
well and of course that some pollo
nowadays it may be due to the day like
the worst reason though the social and
equality in Brazil that means that the
people are completely an equality
distributed in our land in our territory
and some Paulo has become a huge City
very interesting for an arc debt but of
course that it was made by very hard
reason to our country
and some bottle nowadays still I think
that is changing a little bit today but
it is still concentrate a lot of
everything that we do in Brazil it's
very unequal so to have it worth of a
horny here as well I think that's very
very important so and one the last thing
that I'd like to add sometimes I feel
that part of this foreign inter interest
in Brazilian earth that nowadays come
because Brazil could be seen as a very
isolated field were an architecture that
was so important in the world in one
time and that was Putin cries in the
whole world there were preserved in a
way and so it's very hard to find
another place where we can see those
values still taking a very important
role in earth that this is true I think
but this is not all this is not the
whole thing I think that is approach is
not I think that it makes sense is very
well informant but it's not easy to go
to the thickness of our contacts the
reason why these things happen that was
not the best ones and I think that this
generation that we brought here today
they are very like if we're for 20-30
years
trying to have the opportunity to talk
in a more broad group of people and so
this is what we will be able to do at
this time and this is what colunga i
think that is offering to this group of
our cadets and for that field that was
isolated in in a part of Brazil it will
represent it's a thing that everyone
will wish for this but it will be of
course it will bring lots of changing
and and it's like a new time to our
earth detector because we are going to
check if all the values the principles
that we trust so much can be validated
in this kind of much more broad field so
and I think that this is what we are
going to see and try to talk a little
bit tonight so I my suggestion is that
we could follow the order that we have
on the folder so i would suggest to have
Bruno Campos and and and see the desk
starting after cell Udinese and it
worked off a horny thank you
okay sorry um can you heat can you hear
okay so I'm I'd like to thank the
invitation from columbia university is
really a pleasure to be here it's an
honor we really thrilled with the entire
you know brazilian week and also the
presentations at the AAA and APA which
is happening in this week Benjamin and
Benjamin support and the consulate thank
you all for coming also so um I was told
we have 15 minutes I'll try to be brief
you know a presentation so our practice
is a very small practice we are eight
people three partners me to view and
Marcelo who unfortunately couldn't come
here and right now our we just moved to
this house it's an incredible space
first now we are sharing the space with
three more three other practices one is
a landscape designer who helped us in
the pan american games and also in the
Rio 2016 games which is vacio s yeah
Carlos was also supposed to be here but
his is stuck in London because of the
volcano and there is a graphic designer
who happens to be my girlfriend at this
point Mariana Hardy which is very
convenient for the graphic design pot
and and also the third practice which is
a fan on the macula and good friend of
ours and mine is a much adequately so we
refurbish this house it's a house from
their 20s and and we have this lovely
garden where we can have you know
outdoor meetings when the weather is
nice we have also parties there and on
the first floor we have basically you
know more private rooms and second floor
we have to come on areas and they build
a shed the stubble height space which is
you know laughter space where we can
have up to 30 40 people working here so
we also try also to use the space as a
space for presentation so we had you
know what's the name of the guy who did
the maps that went there soon got Garcia
that that was here in the storefront art
gallery like a couple of weeks ago
forgot his name his he works at Hanna
Larssen so he did a presentation there
and we had some British people also
curators so it's a place that did it's
almost like a public space for lectures
and we tried to to keep it active when
when we're not working so um today um so
we've been working mostly recently on
large-scale projects but today we we
decided to show a little bit of
everything so wouldn't give the
impression that we only do large-scale
schemes so start with those furniture
pieces ten years ago I was an intern at
Wiseman Friday architects so they were
working on uris hall the third floor it
was the school centres of PhD centers
I'm not saying so um they asked me to to
try to come up with a furniture piece
that could be you know easily stored and
put away for a conference center day so
that the space good could still be
flexible so they use for other events as
well so I came up with this idea that
you know as like a single sheet of metal
could be cut and you would fold the
pieces with some sort of hinges and then
you could you know either hang it on the
wall or put it away or even leave it on
the floor so was struggling with the
details of that for a week and of course
I couldn't figure it out it was looking
at journal else p
furniture for the maison cartier with
all the complicated structure underneath
to to make it look like it was very thin
on the tabletop but I really couldn't
make it so in the end Michael just said
and Marin you know Blum that's very nice
but why don't we try something else and
so they proposed and they did that's
their final design for the for the
conference room which is of course much
more clever for for the use of the space
you open up the table and you can have
you know book launches there with drinks
on the other side so this was I came
here the Colombian I was doing survey of
the space of thought it was was fun to
show that but when I came back to to
Brazil I decided to resurrect my idea of
the table that I couldn't develop their
so in this case now it's it's I had to
extrude the the plank so it could be
like a slab in terms of structure I
could solve the details more easily so
the idea is I nicknamed it the tatami
table so it has the proportions of at
the timing six feet by by three feet and
the basic modules three inches square
and so I have the lights or 30 inches
and the thickness of three inches so you
fold and fold it in a way that you can
basically carry it easily so that's the
final piece it looks like the massive
plank of wood but only the legs are
massive wood and and the tabletop is is
a light very light structure covered
with wood laminate so it looks like a
massive blank and there is a actually
the table the legs work as a giant screw
so as you screw to tighten it to an up
to
a position where they way they stand
stable and it forms those irregular
tabletop designs so this was a prototype
I made at the time for my my house and
also for my practice and then of course
we did variations on that this is the
same table that when you get bored of
one finishing you can you know change it
it's basically the same same thing so
and this is going into production but
the the manufacturer asked to be in a
different proportion so sorry would sell
better so actually this would be will be
able to fold it and carry in the kind of
the bag out of the store so it would be
easily easily and kind of cheap also
like two hundred dollars at the most so
while of us do me this was also having
other ideas about furniture so and I was
invited by another industry to design a
table was a series of tables designed by
architects so I'm this is the unstable
the idea is that the tabletop looks like
it's it's not it doesn't have really a
surface to be on top of so I try to make
it look very uncomfortable that as if
you would bump into it you know that the
table would just fall apart but actually
there is a quite complicated to tell you
to to make it look like that so it's
like a deception
really so although it looks like it's
it's going to you can also pull the
pieces and change the table top so this
was the only prototype they made and it
never went into protection but hopefully
one day it will so this house was
developed by my my so it's a typical
typology that we work single-family
houses I guess every every every
architect and Angela thank you for the
young one because at this point we're
all 40 so I don't know if we can we can
we can make you know accion architects
but she was 41 and 40 and my cell is 32
38 so so this house was done on the
suburbs so it's a typical program a
couple with couple of kids and it's
quite common in Brazil to have this kind
of of you know middle class upper middle
class hiring architects to make their
own their own their own houses which is
more in common here in America I suppose
the idea was basically to have sorry
that we go back to the site so the idea
there was an existing plateau so we
placed the house on the top of the
plateau for views and also for privacy
reasons so actually as you approach the
hell through this too is reb there is an
eight meter you know difference in terms
of level you don't really see the house
until you get to talk so we have a kind
of a surprise to see the house there so
it's fairly simple we have two on the
left hand side and have the delivery
room with double height space with a
with another space like a cube hanging
on top which is a TV room and then you
have the more
the private rooms on the right hand side
and the kitchen as a separate space and
on the second floor the master bedroom
the nice thing about about his house I
think I mean the big deal the only big
deal i think is that the TV room hanging
on top so the idea is that you know you
can close this base up and be totally
separated from the house so you won't
have any any any noise or or any
disturbance happening so and it's also
connected by it to the bathroom bedroom
by this this kind of catwalk this is the
the viewer I don't have a better phone
throughout that but to you and interview
when you're reaching the house up so
when you look at the pictures you see
literally the box hanging hanging up and
it also makes this otherwise very very
monumental double-height space to get
some it some some some kind of intimate
space underneath it so it defines the
place also even if it's an open space so
you can see the box hanging out and and
the structure this light this light
overhang or disliked a distance between
the facade and the structure is is a
transition form for light and rain which
might look not enough but it's it's it's
really something to have just like a
meter it's amazing how it can protect
and one thing else about this house
that's the view from from the catwalk
which in the box and we don't really
have control over the interior designs
of those rugs and furniture wise and the
good thing about this house also is that
there are
Oh doors so no no windows sorry so it's
outdoors so whenever you use lie the
door you're directly already on on the
ground or on the veranda or on the
terrace so it really has a few sometimes
of being you know outdoors and not
really indoors so this is one
intervention in a favela that we're
going to show and see who is going to to
present it it's a favela in Belo
Horizonte which is that's the plan of
the city and until we will take from
here giving him it's a it's a plan a
google view of ballads on to our CD and
you'll see on the top the popular lake
with the famous near miser work you see
the city ringed the original plant city
100 years ago and how the city grow in
this 100 years and close to the city
center have this favela the sarah & and
the bottle have the coho mountain is the
limit of the city because of the
mountain ok this is favela das a typical
favela in Brazil and the municipality
are working on a project called the
villa villa villa project is one of the
larger intervention in favelas in Brazil
you work in that serious of her veils in
this parameter say there is the like the
first project they are in your
implementation this project we have a
lot of improvements we have the road
road improvement we have the Sanitation
improvement and they are their
construction they are removing the
families from the area of risk and move
them to this this build is there sir
social housing and but the interesting
at the people from Fidel are
stay in the same place there belong so
they're not moving through a far away
from the center they still close to
where the work there is there close to
the where the friends are the neighbors
are and in this project there you have
improvement in parks who have spark
complex and water preservation the
streams of water are being and the speed
this pollution and have this position of
remediation of the water streams and
their plan to make three urban parks in
this favela this a google photo from the
h 30 park departed we working on and
it's in the middle in the heart of
availa in the middle of it we have the
water stream this is the fountainhead
number three of the city and the idea of
the project is the main ideas to
preserve preserve this green arrow in
this park and make a space that people
can leave and play and and this is the
plan of of the park with series of
facilities annex park playground a
community center and sports center and
things like that and it's cut through
the river and only one project now is is
completed is a community center and this
scheme is very simple because you have a
low budget and a very tight schedule so
just a surface the roof under a metal
structure and below it the program
separating in blocks because you have
different functions for different people
at different schedules this is the plan
have the all the thing that happens in
the building the first floor plan have
covered pages open pages cute room
kitchen
fitness room how also you have young
people at the same time I have other
people and grow this this way this is
the second level have workshops meeting
room administration social system
computer on administrate go up this is a
model of the building the idea is to to
build firstly the roof so under the roof
you can you can continue the
construction and protected by the rain
so the work is keeping go and any you
can keep the disk Adam on time this is a
photo of this metal metal roof there's
perforated is still plate and you can
see material through it and the colors
this integration with the nature and the
trees you see the two types of
construction the steel construction and
underneath and below it a very low cost
low tech construction that go inside it
this is the perforate steel metal plate
pay to this is the build completed is
and it looked like a photoshop but it's
the real thing and and the structures
look like and finish but that's the idea
because we are the automated it's a very
open space that invites people to go
inside it to into integrated inside and
the outside this is the covert pager
inside you have the and the roof has
this dis opening so you frame the
outside views you see the trees and some
time to see the favela science
Braun is going to continue Thank so that
pan american games in 2005 we started to
design with larger design detailed or
cluster this is on a north North Zone of
Rio which is a kind of a suburban area
not the kind of American suburbs the
definition of the meaning of suburbs in
Rio it's quite dif different it's really
like a working-class area this is one of
the poorest area in Rio and it's a very
unique context we have here on the on
this side we have really a favela it's a
neighborhood called maganos Buster's you
could see the irregular you know the
organic organization of the settlement
here we have a military village with its
neatly organized pavilions and buildings
and here we have those incredible you
know fields of polo that the military
used to you know to practice and it's
basically carpets of green grass and in
the back of this area some mountains
with lush lens forests and also in this
area so all this area is cut is cut
through Avenida Brasil which is a sort
of a hybrid between a highway and and
motorway so at the same time it unites
you know the borough's it separates the
area so we did today we're talking about
just the shooting center just to be
quick but we did the question center and
the modern pentathlon the grass hockey
and the archer fields as well so this
the site plan the same the idea is to
have a cluster connected by pathway so
you can spend the entire day there
during the games and also this has
triggered a renovation of the entire
area with improvement of infrastructure
and an urban fixtures as well so this is
the shooting center this is basically a
series of pavilions shooting ranges
connected by a spine circulation for
some reasons they are all have to face
south so you approach you have the
entrance of the building you know
towards the directions of the shooting
which is quite dramatic when when
they're practicing or when there is
competitions you're actually entering
through the line of fire and so we have
this long building overall we have
almost like one kilometer from one point
to another the building has 50,000
square meters this is a google earth
recently looks like a drawing with a
with plan with it with the shadows it's
quite quite amazing there a photo with
the mountains and back and so this is
just like the overall organization after
shooting center it's pretty like a
diagram actually we have the spine of
circulation connected to the to the
shooting ranges and the public go up the
ramp and and they flow independently
from the accredited which are all go
from a separate entrance and so you
don't have a mixture of flows in terms
of accredited security athletes and
operations and attended the public who
has paid tickets so it's an eye to
consider the landscape on the back and
kind of floating overhang of this trap
and skeet and and that's another image
of Afghan Trista Co it's basically
concrete exposed concrete when we do
buildings public buildings we try to our
strategies to make sure there are no
details or are not really no details but
there is no accessories so everything is
crucial let's say for instance that when
the structure is done the architecture
is done because from our experience
otherwise you know things because of
budget adjustment state they just they
don't get done so in this case we have
basically exposed concrete the still
frame end and the corrugated roof you
know turning around becoming a wall and
in glass and the wood baffles which
actually have a reason they're here to
to prevent the bullets from scaping from
the fields of play so in this section
you see you know this is where the
accredited you know flow the public
flows here and they go straight into the
stands you know from from up here and
the athletes go from the lower level and
this main concourse a very stark as you
can see and so we try just to to have
you know light and air and circulation
and open to to the landscape and those
are the shooting baffles 22 inches thick
of wood so this is supposed to to be you
know destroyed the time it the shooters
they don't really miss the target
that's a precedent field of play there's
an indoor a stand that is the only one
that needs air conditioning so we could
face himself so this is like a you know
lounge area so we try also to in
Brazil's possible to have this you know
outdoor activities and this transition
spaces between inside and outside we're
on strike two to work with that because
the weather allows it to happen it's
very nice to be you know indoors and
outdoors at the same time so this is the
grandstand of the trap and skeet very
simple also with the steel rods and back
holding your hand and a huge concrete
wall and that's it for the I'm 2008 we
were hired by the Olympic Committee to
be responsible for them for the
architecture and landscape after Rio
2016 bit so we worked exclusively
exclusively on that for almost a year
and a half and yesterday we we presented
the master plans of the auto four
clusters and at the APA so we presented
the Baha'i tijuca cluster the del dotto
this is the bar that you closer by the
way the daughter cluster Copacabana and
also the Moroccan and clusters and
that's a view of the Olympic Park and
since we talked about it yesterday I
we're just mentioning that way we did
that end on friday we'll have that the
center for architecture we'll talk about
some of the buildings from the Olympic
bid the IBC MPC which is this image the
media press center and
national broadcast center and then the
aquatics center and also the ITC the
indoor training center so if you whoever
is interested it's on friday at 6pm that
so thank
first I would like to thank you for this
opportunity especially mr. ma Quigley
and Benjamin broski it's a great one or
two be here in fact was when I was
invited to to be here I was planning to
study here so you can imagine how I feel
now somehow I feel like presenting my
work to professor in a final review I
hope I go well my name is Sarah genus
and I am partner in the office dejected
wood which was founded in 2001 after we
want the Silverado contest and since its
foundation we the film has been involved
in a wide variety of projects cave since
house to entire neighborhood nowadays we
are six architects and two trainees
sharing a 60 square metres space based
in here jr. I'd like to to talk about
our method of work different from the
regular way we try to understand the
project as a kind of spiral path that
allows us to go round you until we
achieve the final objective that should
be a good project in accordance to
our climate conditions the spiral method
letters review the strategies of the
project that may be wrong according to
the environmental comfort modeling and
I'd like to present two projects in more
details and then I will just show some
pictures of others others projects first
I will present the silk uvidel and then
the cruiser school during during the 80s
silver dome was an important concert
venue with a informal and breezy
atmosphere it was significant to the
city because it was responsible for
lunch launching a great number of
Brazilian hot rock bands and despite its
importance silpada was closed by the
city hall in 1996 because its facilities
didn't provides the acoustic protection
to required to ensure comfort to the
neighboring residents in 2001 in
response to many requests the city how
decided to reopen the space but now with
a proper soundproofing so a national
competition was launched it and we want
it and wondering how the new supervisor
should be we started to think about
music dance and movement because
naturally music and dance deals with
movement and
especially because the name safada means
flying circles this movement should be a
movement of circles preparing to fly and
this movement should generate a kind of
vortex that would affect the other
buildings around it so we tried to apply
movement in all octet rule elements
around the main space this is the main
space and we try to freeze this movement
as in this as shown in this pictogram
this is the contest modeling this is the
main entrance the main space dressing
rooms this building for administration
in restrooms a kind of balcony the
second space and the bar this is the
final rendering and this is a de City
front cover of first resonance concept
it's interesting to to see how
architecture was perceived by the design
as you know this is the main entrance
the back facade with those perforated
concrete walls that was that were
supposed to be painted by graffiti
graffiti artists here the administration
building and in the back the dressing
rooms building both protected from the
West Sun here again the perforated
concrete walls designed by us and here
the main space with its that space was
designed to support an audience of 1,500
people and we wanted every internal and
external space connected to each other
covering the main area with that
instance tensile membrane was a premise
of the contest despite the its poor
acoustic performance and in order to
solve this problem we design a second
membrane beneath the main one and
composed of insulating materials and set
out in different positions and hear of
the 1000 and 500 people near to the
stage
here this stage this is not another
project it's the wizard school a project
of ten thousand square meters addition
to conceal school head quaters based in
Rio to that we made as ma'sha'allah
partners this project has won some
awards such such as the second prize in
the light Latin American phase of the
hosting a word for sustainable
construction and others here I'd like to
show the Sun path on the on the left the
Sun path of the city regional just to
show the need of protection even in the
South passage and here here we have the
temperatures of from 61 to 90 in Rio and
the temperatures of New York last year
so it's completely different and we
don't have to to be concerned about the
lowers temperatures
but in fact the temperatures have
increased so much since Knighton's that
achieved 122 degrees Fahrenheit last
january january it means higher
temperatures that them some desert areas
but unfortunately with warm nights too
and when we were invited to design this
sustainable school we started to think
about our modernist heritage and how
these updates used projects in
accordance to our climate and we
realized that we lost those appropriate
solutions such as brizola to achieve the
correct orientation of buildings natural
ventilations and this is the site a red
prepared with different plateaus to
receive a building in many levels as the
client was expecting but we decided to
project the building following the Sun
path orientation to avoid heat gains in
east and west facets which made the site
plan and space between the building
richer talk about program here we have
the main entrance this space distributes
the flow between the two wings and other
spaces oops sorry the second floor
administration here we have an
auditorium the labs the classrooms in
those two wings and in central position
the library connecting the two wings in
front of garden internal garden and this
skin show us the strategies with abduct
to improve the environmental comfort in
the internal and external spaces
here is a detailed section of one wing
showing how the facets elements work
quick animation I hope it works
you can see it in youtube if you want we
have a channel there and just a few
images of other projects this is the
ferryboat station pass the Kings
ferryboat station so arena I might talk
about it too on Friday the silver door
day nursery I will present this project
to on Friday this is a penthouse in a
very important building modernist
building designed by George warrior
called Cephas sepas building with a
great view of cocoa pod
this is our last project we finished two
weeks ago it's the medina glider for the
marina Gloria contest we have a high
limit hi limitation we couldn't go
beyond 15 meters and here the Sugarloaf
as you know you try to do a very flat
building this is the main entrance it's
a kind of sports and business facility I
think more business than sport facility
here we have the Gloria hotel in the
back another entrance
none of you
that's it thank you very much good
evening I'm Edward fair honey and first
of all I like to say that I'm still 33
so I I can be a little little bit more
relaxed about the mistakes that I might
show so but i would like to start I
would like to thank first columbia
university under the invitation to say
that's a pleasure to be here with my
friends and I would like to compliment
blue components Celgene is for the very
impressive work that you show tonight
for us I'd like to start this
presentation talking a little bit about
our practice and the way we organize our
services as a group we work in what you
call a cooperative of our cadets which
means basically that there is a number
of small offices generally with two or
three partners all working within the
same space which is this a commercial
gallery my firm is called hnf is part of
this cooperative we have been working
together for eight years in different
arrangements also with other more
established offices and we have taken
advantage of exchanging ideas in this
more informally let's say as we don't
have too much time at
to extend myself I'm going only to
present some of this the place that we
work and now so only to project so I put
the website here for those who might be
interested in in systema for other work
I also like to say that they are kids
that presented tonight are exposing here
and also we have one building they're
exposed and it's an honor to participate
on its exhibition house for us for the
young let me put the other our office is
located in a very particular urban
situation in the center of some Paula
disease this is the whole center of the
old center of the city this area where
we work this is more the place where we
work is densely occupied by modern high
highest buildings from the thirties
through the seventies but all of them
are implanted into these very narrow and
irregular plots from the 19th century
but I would like to show a plan which is
this because what I think the interest
interesting point about these buildings
is that they have established a new net
of pedestrian walkways which is you in
this plan which functions as commercial
galleries on the ground floors of which
building while in the upper floors their
offices apartments hotels and so on but
in this place where there's a huge
concentration of people these buildings
offer a new ground of public space
english k is a kind of seat inside the
old existing city this this building
here is the famous copper building
designer by oscar niemeyer i live on
this place here and i walked through
here and i go work on these other
building here so we we have our office
in this building which also the
commercial gallery did jesus computing
this is the ground floor which is very
interesting which is sloped slab is that
right slope slab ground floor very
interesting and and this is the place
where we work with Scott Korea metropoli
it's another building from the 60s and
of course these are not new worked at
Roy dias but I think that for us it
works as a very up-to-date example of
how architecture can create a strong and
active interface with the city so in
this sense the project that i would like
to present tonight reflect somehow on
this concern of of how of the urban
interface of the beauty so this
this first project here is a we had just
design it for a competition we are still
waiting for the results by date i can
show you it's not a problem no it's
sudden now it's oh but it is it's design
it was designed it for a new
Presbyterian Church in the Asian
neighborhood of Liberdade which this is
a picture of liberdade and next to the
center of some power and this church
will be built by this community who has
written recently immigrated to brazil
and for whom that the whole church works
as a strong social and cultural
reference in a foreign city for them the
temple itself is therefore associated
with many other facilities like
restaurant nursery school and sports and
nowaday nowadays these programs are
dispersing small plots all on the street
creating a very special situation the
city where it is very closed community
appears in the public space and the
street becomes a kind of living room for
them so this this is the existing church
the student the sports here and they all
open to the street and they they gather
here so they they bought a bigger plot
of land here which is on the other side
of the street to expand their activities
and to build a new church in this place
and our aim
is now to intensify this presence of the
Vario various programs on the street
bring in the public sidewalk into the
interior of the block which is here and
also trying to connect both streets so
we split the program into three separate
buildings rising out from a common
basement which here which accommodates
car parking restaurant and
administration and this is the church
which implanted flush with the street
and this is this is the old existing
church so we try to implant the whole
volume is in order to create an axis
from the old church to this space here
and this open space inside the plot
should function as a kind of a
churchyard that concentrates the access
to the main collective problems the
ground floor is split into two levels
from the street one can either step back
to the church or go down a soft slope to
the restaurant which is here and the
narrow building which on the corner with
the Main Street supposed to represent a
more public face of of the church to the
Korean of the Korean community and the
church to the city so this building is
placed in order to open the perspective
from the corner of the main street to
the church and on the ground father's a
gallery for public events and an
exhibition on the upper levels of the
same building there are the cabinets for
the preacher so you see a preacher
very sharmila so this just church did
this sorry this third building here on
the back which we thought as being quite
independent and different from the
others we accommodate the lecture rooms
nursery school and other supporting
functions and it also provides the
connection with the flower street which
is on the other side the sort of public
connection the interior this is these
are some images from the entrance
someone going up and to this churchyard
this is the old church the access to the
new church and the temple that we
thought that could be very simple just
with some light openings there's a light
shed on the back of this textile there's
very interesting Korean textile work and
the core I do see the score chorus yeah
it's a it's a kind of outside volume
that intercepts the church from the
outside and there are some sunlight that
comes from the the bed from the sides
whoa then we thought that will be very
interesting to to bring some unexpected
light for the gospel Korean singers like
this so on the second projects project
which i would like to show the school
that is a public school which was
designed in partnership with this
another off seer called bourassa
Nakamura and it's part of a program
program for the construction of hundreds
of new public schools in the state of
são Paulo this is
the whole metropolitan area of the city
of San Paulo is like 80 kilometers 40
these white dots are the new school so
I'm planted in the outskirts and they
represent an important reference for
these poor outskirts of the cities were
most of them are implanted not only the
siege of sample cause January there's a
great lack of public facilities in those
plays so in order to have I standard
quality for the construction of the
schools the government has adopted a
very ordinary precast concrete structure
which is actually more commonly used for
warehouses Jesus Jesus day school is not
a warehouse but when you look at the
entire set of school designed by
different actors there are some
interesting variations in the use of
these rough materials and construction
details the neighborhood where the
school was implanted this land which was
recently reorganized it consists mostly
of low highs but extremely dense
occupation a very few there are very few
collective spaces remaining as you can
see in this picture so the plan the
government planned to to build two
schools and a health center on the last
ain't empty plot of land which is just
inside the square on the mouth of the
river this is the main river of some
powder but we are very fine least but
this site was quite small for the
commish for the three facilities
actually we were commissioned with one
of the schools in the other I was to be
designed by this friend of ours which I
also was our former professor very
generous guy Antonio Carlos Barassi he
teaches at whose belief
Bujji and we decided to to put both
schools into one building and to do the
project together so in order to achieve
a more compact occupation and to create
more open spaces on the side the main
difference between the two programs is
the age of the purpose populous but did
the children you know so we decided that
the younger children should have more
outdoor spaces for recreation time this
is the yellow school for the younger
children and for the other children we
build sports hall and Recreation on the
top of the whole beauty so can you see
there's a pink thing here so this is the
school for the older children this is
for the small children so one goes on to
the top of the other and in order to
this distinguish one school from the
Audrey created a void between them that
also shows the vertical dimension of the
building from the inside these are the
plans and a section here the facades
were built with very simple tile blocks
as a sem breaker detached from the
windows which this that took much time
to build and from the outside the sun
breakers gives a sense of unity 2 g's
internal variations of the building and
there's also a kind of play with the
opacity and transparence depending on
the light conditions and the building
acts now as a kind of reference to this
entire bible neighborhood as its main
public equipment because it's all very
low so the building appears on from
everywhere so this is people go to the
boys going to school and the building's
always
and appearing and this at the entrance
of the school there's a small square
that parents and the children gather and
the reception desk the all the space is
here open directly to the to d square
there's about there are about
approximately a thousand students
attending the schools and these are some
pictures that people going inside the
building and this is their children
going up so this is the recreation area
for the older children and this is a set
of other schools just finish because i
think it's interesting sure to show that
we've have been designing for the same
government program in different
situations but i think that maybe what
matters is the whole range of new school
building quantities to comply with this
immense depth of public education so in
the exhibition that you see outside
there are very interesting schools
design it for the same program designed
by many other actors so that's it no I
wanted to show
we are pleased Brutus you silver please
now we have a very short time now but
anyway we would like to open if you have
any question for our presenters please
you were showing these these Sun pad
diagrams and I was wondering what are
the humidity conditions over there
humidity you were showing is waterfall
and humidity it's very high it's kind of
eighty percent specifically in huge
annual and you know it's a bad a very
big problem you when you that you have
the humility with warm conditions
alright I think that were you saw in the
presentation general were project that
building always in different condition
some but they I think that they can give
us a very good panorama to show what the
the work that our tats are engaging
Brazil at this time I mean there are
some actions those that are much more
promote the broad know that the Olympic
Games that is something that is just
starting or the project that Sal you
showed us that came from competition in
Rio it's not Brazil after the end of the
dictatorship period of course that
architecture is start to recover some
space that we used to have to discuss to
publish to architecture in Brazil and
competition there is something that just
start after that time so we are still I
think creating a culture about this very
important space mostly for young guard
death know and and
the presentation that was made by Duarte
horn if I take one work as well of
course that the public school that he
showed us and sad that it is just one
school in a more than 100 in school that
are spread in the whole some paulo state
it shows an action of our government
there in Brazil that create a way to
invite some mark debts to to design
those those schools and being with all
of you but you said at the very
beginning of the of your conference
Angela said that uh to be an object you
have to have a concept no you have to
have an idea of what you want to express
with you with your building in your
professional I'd like to know to anyone
of you who wants to answer how do you
think your building upon that modern
tradition you've inherited and in what
way have you have you differentiated
from it and are building your own
concept of what Brazilian architecture
could be
I sorry I think this is a very difficult
question maybe I don't feel capable
answering but I would like to say
something with it now I think that more
than express I i should say that I'm our
interests interested in provide some
situations that I think that are very
interesting examples in modern Brazilian
architect actor architecture but also in
many other but because we're talking
about Brazilian architecture I think it
it gives many interesting examples of
how architecture can create a more
interesting seating so in my opinion
that that is more to provide something
than to express I'm not so interested in
that I would say but I'm not so it's
only that my my idea I a idea that that
I have now about this very difficult
question just wanna say just just
quickly as you know Brazil's full of
contrasts and sometimes shocking
dualities and and the mixture and which
is part of its charm for sure but
sometimes it's it can it can become
quite you know a mess and you know the
only thing that we don't really I mean
I'm speaking for myself we don't really
have you know a strategy or method which
is very rigorous with we just try to do
it in a way that we don't celebrate it
or or we don't you know go against it so
so this is a thin line that we are
always trying to do you know
not to fix a situation which is almost
like unfixable and not you know to also
be celebrating a sort of very extreme
contrast that can be very interesting
but also very problematic so we are
always dealing with those issues and
particularly what we try to do is
basically we're very interested also in
the and one of the very good things
about working in Brazil is that you can
work on the inside on the outside and
have this this transition between the
inside and the outside and much fluid
weight and then another climate so this
is also something that we have to do but
some pollo school as Angela mentioned is
more is much more you have more method
and more and more more structure so to
speak so I think we there was this
exhibit called beyond uncock modern in
Paris right which could be either
flattering or or also like it could be a
not flattering at all because it's still
modern so so I thought it was being
French you know the title of the exhibit
from here I didn't see it as a
flattering comment but it might be
because we all loved you know the modern
classics of Brazilian architecture so
we're still in this striving to go
beyond modern I think Gracie one thing
when I make me makes me remind remember
when I came to hear when I was arriving
in the airport the border security guy
asking what we will do here all those
questions and I explained I will be part
on event of talk about Brazil
architecture and he asked me ok and what
is the Brazil actor textured and I
I told him it's better you go there and
find out with me because it's a very
difficult question too we have a lot of
different scenarios so it's we don't
have anymore brazilian capture as we
used to have in the past we have a
different ways of architecture I guess
but I think even in the past that the
architecture was different in any case
it wasn't just one Brazilian
architecture I mean it was maybe present
it like that but it wasn't really if you
look at it carefully and the one thing
that I find very refreshing and and
remarkable is the directness of the work
and and the proportional this feeling
for the proportion of space and I in for
public space I mean I think those things
you know you use all up in different
ways all have in common you know and
that directness and commitment to public
space i think is not it's really
refreshing I think very refreshing and
and that aspect in in many ways has been
lost i think as as as a sort of
responsibility that the professional
should have to society and I find that
very impressive and this is the use of
the school buildings as a kind of
reassertion of a hope in a way and also
as a sort of public core for the Lisa
this is this these favelas etc you know
is it's really very very impressive
I I think that our time is over no bit
and and I know I just like to add no
there is no better way to finish then
with a comment by a friend that well
thank you so much thank you can for
something up and thank you everyone to
our panel I would like to say that our
our local brownies has done their best
with some Brazilian appetizers outside
please enjoy the exhibit curated by
syrup R&D and and the work from Brazil
and please there's another event at
studio x tomorrow and exhibit and
there's a final panel on the
architecture of the olympics on friday
so we hope to keep seeing you this week
thank you for coming